Katrina: 今天有没有好吃的
Katrina: Is there anything good to eat today?
其他人：一楼还有一个汉堡
Others: There's still a hamburger on the first floor.
Shure: 来把这个清理一下
Shure: Come on, clean this up.
Katrina: 这个桌面是干嘛的
Katrina: What's this table for?
其他人：这个桌面是放行李
Shure: 她们俩放行李
Shure: DJ台懂吗
Shure: It's a DJ booth, you know?
Shure: 菊次郎没有熬过的夏天
Shure: Juzo's summer that didn't make it.
其他人：给你找个凳子
Others: Let me get you a chair.
Shure: 这应该不能吃了吧
Shure: This probably can't be eaten, right?
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my god
Shure: 这真的是土耳其的吗
Shure: Is this really from Turkey?
Jake:创作歌手
Jake: A singer-songwriter
Shure: 你的土耳其
Shure: Your Turkey
Shure: 我的土耳其
Shure: My Turkey
Shure: 好像不一样是吧
Shure: Seems different, right?
其他人：好像不一样
Others: Seems different
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Whoa
Shure: 你这土耳其真的跟我们的很很不一样
Shure: Your Turkey is really very different from ours.
Jake:你这土耳其在打仗啊
Jake: Your Turkey is at war.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Shure: Jazz版土耳其是吧
Shure: Jazz version of Turkey, right?
Shure: 啊我操
Shure: Ah, damn
Shure: 到时候视频就是
Shure: The video will be
Shure: 哎我去
Shure: Oh my god
Shure: 雅
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 这小扇是谁的呀
Shure: Whose little fan is this?
Tasha: 你会咬扇子吗
Tasha: Can you bite the fan?
Tasha: 哈哈哈能咬能咬能咬
Tasha: Hahaha you can bite it, you can bite it, you can bite it
Shure: 能咬吗能咬能咬
Shure: Can you bite it? You can bite it, you can bite it
Tasha: 展开再咬然后合上的
Tasha: Open it, then bite it, and then close it.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Jake:多多少刚出院
Jake: How much did you just get out of the hospital
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Jake:出院多久了
Jake: How long since you got discharged?
Shure: 麦克风
Shure: Microphone.
Jake:我要干什么
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 把被子叠上
Tasha: Fold the quilt.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 行谢谢你
Tasha: Alright, thank you.
Shure: 7天第一次叠叠被子是吧
Shure: First time folding a quilt in 7 days, right?
Tasha: 谁7 你天天叠吗
Tasha: Who said 7? Do you fold it every day?
Shure: 我不叠啊
Tasha: 那不就行了
Tasha: Then that's settled.
Jake:那那也是七天
Jake: Well, that's still 7 days.
Tasha: 把被子放这
Tasha: Put the quilt here.
Tasha: 好像没有到两张床的长度吧
Tasha: It doesn't seem to be the length of two beds.
Tasha: 你会不会太过分了
Tasha: Are you being too much?
其他人：忘了
Others: Forgot.
其他人：我靠你还会这个
Others: Wow, you can even do this?
Tasha: 不得不嫁了是吧已经
Tasha: Looks like you have to get married already.
其他人：快了是拦不下了
Others: It's soon, can't stop it now.
Jake:完了一天求婚80遍我靠
Jake: Oh my, proposing 80 times a day.
其他人：你学的电子琴还是钢琴
其他人：钢琴
Others: Regular piano.
其他人：这你听过
Others: Have you heard this?
其他人：我听过但我不知道名字
Others: I've heard it but don't know the name.
其他人：这是匈牙利狂想曲第二部
其他人：来个谱子我来介绍一下
Others: Give me the sheet music, I'll introduce it.
其他人：卧槽这个我真不会
Others: Oh man, I really can't do this.
其他人：那建议今天你表演
Others: Then I suggest you perform today.
其他人：你快来表演一个
Others: Come on, perform one.
其他人：匈牙利狂想曲
Others: Hungarian Rhapsody.
Jake:建议你们看看有没有火药杆
Jake: Suggest you check if there's any firework sticks.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人：我已经串完了
Others: I've already finished the string.
其他人：建议你现在点外卖啊
Others: Suggest you order takeout now.
Tasha: 两个串都串完了
Tasha: Both strings are done.
其他人：哦还有他那个场
Others: Oh, there's also his scene.
其他人：没事马上我就去穿
Others: No problem, I'll go string it soon.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:哇那你点
Jake: Wow, then you order.
Jake:你问他们想吃什么
Jake: Ask them what they want to eat.
其他人：我的评价是元记云饺
Others: My review is for Yuanji Cloud Dumplings.
Jake:好行那你开吧
Jake: Alright, you start then.
其他人：不如吃米村拌饭
Others: Why not have Micun Mixed Rice?
Tasha: 我也觉得米村拌饭好吃
Tasha: I also think Micun Mixed Rice is delicious.
Tasha: 搜就知道了
Tasha: Just search it, you'll know.
其他人：预制菜top.1
其他人：预制菜那我不要
Others: I don't want pre-made dishes.
Shure: 老老北京就好这口
Shure: Old Beijingers love this stuff.
其他人：我要源记云饺
Others: I want Yuanji Cloud Dumplings.
其他人：还有预制菜
Others: And pre-made dishes.
其他人： 就是比较健康
Others: They're relatively healthy.
Jake:别的可是也是预制菜
Jake: But others are also pre-made dishes.
Jake:只是没告诉你自己
Jake: Just didn't tell you.
Tasha: 云记云饺也是预制菜
Tasha: Yuanji Cloud Dumplings are also pre-made dishes.
其他人：真的吗真的
Others: Really? Really?
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Tasha: 每天小车拉过来的
Tasha: Delivered by small cars every day.
Jake:那就就吃那个什么叫什么
Jake: Then let's just eat that... what's it called?
Jake:白饭哈哈
Jake: Plain rice, haha.
Tasha: 米村拌饭
Tasha: Micun Mixed Rice.
Jake:米村拌饭
Jake: Micun Mixed Rice.
Jake:Ok
Jake: Ok
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
其他人： 这个还是不错的
Others: This one's pretty good.
其他人：最远从领展购物广场送过来
Others: The furthest delivery is from Link Shopping Plaza.
其他人：看时间看时间看时间
Others: Check the time, check the time, check the time.
其他人： 知道56分钟可以
Others: Knowing 56 minutes is fine.
其他人：我不知道哎
Others: I don't know.
其他人：你上次点的是那个领展店吗
Others: Did you order from the Link store last time?
Jake:我我我这次拨你
Jake: I, I, I'll call you this time.
Tasha: 就是那个10块钱配送费的
Tasha: It's the one with a 10 yuan delivery fee.
Tasha: 就他
Tasha: That's the one.
其他人：好那就他
Tasha: 就他一家
其他人：嗯哎
Others: Hmm, yeah.
其他人：亲爱的点几个菜
Others: Dear, how many dishes are you ordering?
其他人：你怎么这么熟练
Others: How are you so skilled?
其他人：因为他们上次吃的这家我觉得还可以
Others: Because they ate from this place last time and I thought it was okay.
其他人：好那我单独点个源记云饺
Others: Okay, I'll order Yuanji Cloud Dumplings separately.
其他人：我觉得源记云饺会快
Others: I think Yuanji Cloud Dumplings will be faster.
其他人：我可以先吃上
Others: Can I start eating first?
其他人：这么饿我饿
Others: I'm so hungry, really hungry.
其他人：我饿
Others: I'm hungry.
其他人：我还会我会最简单的
Others: I can do it, I can do the simplest one.
Jake:好听
Jake: Sounds good.
Jake:牛逼虽然是这是啥呀
Jake: Awesome, but what is this?
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: This, haha.
Jake:这啥呀哦嘿
Jake: What's this? Oh hey.
Jake:行行行自创了是吧
Jake: Alright, alright, it's self-made, right?
其他人：自创歌曲
Others: Self-made song.
Jake:自创歌曲
Jake: Self-made song.
其他人：几个人四五六七八九十个人
Others: A few people, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten people.
Lucia: 哦这是巴赫
Lucia: Oh, this is Bach.
Lucia: 的一个小步舞曲是吧
Lucia: A minuet, right?
Lucia: 好像是练完拜
Lucia: It's like after practicing Bayer.
Lucia: 练完拜厄的第一首曲子就弹这个
Lucia: The first piece after practicing Bayer, you play this.
其他人：啊东西好友给你点吗
Others: Ah, good stuff, want me to give you some points?
其他人：你是可以先走
Others: You can go first.
其他人：我也想吃源记云饺
Others: I also want to eat Yuan Ji Yun Dumplings.
Jake:挺好鼓手
Jake: Pretty good, drummer.
Jake:咱就干鼓手的事情哈哈哈
Jake: Let's just do the drummer's job, haha.
Lucia: 六个加四个十个人
Shure: 鼓手怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with the drummer?
其他人：这谁的手机
Others: Whose phone is this?
Shure: 鼓手我还可以弹这个呢
Shure: Drummer, I can still play this.
Jake:大家都点完了
Jake: Everyone ordered?
其他人：对 10个人
Others: Yes, ten people.
Jake:好那就直接下单了
Jake: Alright, then let's place the order.
其他人：10个人每人20块
其他人：呃200块钱
Others: Uh, two hundred bucks.
Jake:这么便宜
Jake: So cheap.
其他人：让我看一眼
Others: Let me take a look.
其他人：我看一眼
Jake:你再看一眼
Jake: You look again.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Haha.
其他人：1234567 呃
Others: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, uh...
Lucia: 感觉
Lucia: Feels like...
其他人：海洋风的
Others: Ocean vibe.
Lucia: 对但是我感觉这个
Lucia: Yeah, but I feel like this...
Lucia: 就是因为他本身是应该撕下来
Lucia: It's because they should be peeled off.
Lucia: 这些贴墙上的
Lucia: These ones on the wall.
Lucia: 但我又害怕这些贴墙上会撕不下来
Lucia: But I'm worried they won't come off easily.
Lucia: 所以大的那几个
Lucia: So for the big ones,
Lucia: 我都是给他后面粘了胶带贴的
Lucia: I used tape on the back to stick them on.
Lucia: 但是他不是有颜色吗
Lucia: But they aren't colorless.
Lucia: 就是本来应该透明
Lucia: They should be transparent.
Lucia: 就是边上都是透明的
Lucia: The edges should be transparent.
Lucia: 这样他就变白了然后就没那么好看了
Lucia: So they turned white and don't look as nice.
Lucia: 救命
Lucia: Oh no.
Lucia: 我想先牺牲一点美观性
Lucia: I want to sacrifice a bit of aesthetics first.
Violet: “这个是你的房间”
Lucia: 对啊现在有点乱就是哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, it's a bit messy now, haha.
其他人：我进来了
Other: I'm coming in.
Lucia: 啊进来进来
Lucia: Ah, come in, come in.
Lucia: 没事就是有点乱
Lucia: It's okay, just a bit messy.
Lucia: 这个这个星星
Lucia: This, this star.
Lucia: 其实我有点想把它直接贴上
Lucia: Actually, I kind of want to stick it on directly.
Lucia: 然后这个应该能撕下来吧
Lucia: This one should come off easily, right?
Lucia: 这么小
Lucia: It's so small.
其他人：对
Other: Yeah.
Lucia: 对大的大的就算了
Lucia: Yeah, forget about the big ones.
Lucia: 小的我觉得可以直接这样对
Lucia: I think the small ones can be stuck on directly.
其他人：你现在还在录着是吗
Other: Are you still recording?
Lucia: 哦对哈哈
Lucia: Oh, yeah, haha.
Lucia: 虽然我房间有点乱
Lucia: Although my room is a bit messy,
Lucia: 但是貌似好像大家都在录的样子
Lucia: It seems like everyone is recording.
Lucia: 所以应该房间里也是可以录的
Lucia: So I guess it's okay to record in the room too.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then,
其他人：这挺有那个味的
Other: This has a nice vibe.
Lucia: 是吧本来想再买一个
Lucia: Right? I originally wanted to buy another one.
Lucia: 就是那个舵可以放在上面那种装饰
Lucia: Like a decorative helm to put on it.
Lucia: 但是后面我想一下
Lucia: But then I thought,
Lucia: 那个可能要在墙上打钉才能固定住
Lucia: It might need nails to fix it to the wall.
Lucia: 就没买
Lucia: So I didn't buy it.
Lucia: 本来这个也是要就是可能固定在
Lucia: Originally, this one also needed to be fixed.
Lucia: 大概就是我本来想的是这个位置
Lucia: I wanted it to be around this position.
Lucia: 对就是让网把它遮住一点
Lucia: To let the net cover it a bit.
Lucia: 然后后面发现挂不住
Lucia: But then I found it wouldn't hang.
Lucia: 对挂不住就只能放在这了很烦
Lucia: Yeah, it wouldn't hang, so I had to put it here. Very annoying.
Shure: now let's welcome to ego life world
Shure: Now let's welcome you to the ego life world.
Lucia: 哈哈外面为什么
Lucia: Haha, why is it outside?
其他人：味太臭了味太臭了
Others: It smells so bad, it smells so bad.
Lucia: 已经开始打碟了
Lucia: They've already started DJing.
Shure: today we will have a great and brain party
Shure: Today we will have a great and brain party.
Lucia: 啊我觉得我要弄不完了
Lucia: Ah, I feel like I won't be able to finish this.
Shure: it's called ego party
Shure: It's called the ego party.
Shure: YO,YO
Jake:我操
Jake: Damn it.
Lucia: 这怎么办
Lucia: What should we do?
Lucia: 我把这拿进去看看
Lucia: I'll take this inside and see.
其他人：哎呀卧槽
Others: Oh my god!
Jake:要不抓几个人下去打工吧
Jake: How about we grab a few people to work downstairs?
Lucia: 靠有种搞不完
Lucia: Damn, feels like we can't finish this.
Lucia: 的错觉哈哈哈
Lucia: It's an illusion, haha.
Jake:你下去打工吧
Jake: You go work downstairs.
Jake:要不下去收拾收拾
Jake: Or go downstairs and clean up.
Lucia: 啊咋办咋办咋办咋办怎么办
Lucia: Ah, what to do, what to do, what to do, what to do?
Lucia: 怎么办怎么办
Lucia: What to do, what to do?
Shure: （歌词）怀着冷暖与嘲笑
Shure: (Lyrics) With warmth and ridicule.
Shure: （歌词）怀着热闹的
Shure: (Lyrics) With a lively...
Shure: （歌词）天空海阔
Shure: (Lyrics) The vast sky and sea.
Shure: （歌词）原谅我一生不羁放纵爱自由
Shure: (Lyrics) Forgive me for a lifetime of unruly love for freedom.
Shure: （歌词）也会怕有一天会跌倒oh no
Shure: (Lyrics) And fear that one day I might fall, oh no.
Shure: （歌词）谁人都可以
Shure: (Lyrics) Anyone can...
Alice:太优雅了
Alice: So elegant.
Alice:啊微微你咋样了
Alice: Ah, Tasha, how are you?
Shure: 好OK
Shure: Okay, okay.
Shure: 呀
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我说句话
Shure: Let me say something.
Shure: 他现在就会有点耶
Shure: He's going to be like, yeah.
Shure: 哎不对
Shure: Oh wait, no.
Shure: 不够等一下
Shure: Not enough, hold on.
Shure: cowarding scent
Shure: Cowarding scent.
Shure: yeah response in the tab going in
Shure: Yeah, response in the tab going in.
Shure: novembering i feel so lonely
Shure: Novembering, I feel so lonely.
Shure: so decided gonna be my soul
Shure: So decided gonna be my soul.
其他人：修硕你来唱我来弹
Others: Shure, you sing, I'll play.
Shure: 谈什么
Shure: Play what?
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: Sing what?
Jake:呃呃呃呵呵
Jake: Uh uh uh haha
Shure: 你在唱什么呀
Shure: What are you singing?
Lucia: 啊整不完了整不完了我靠啊救命啊
Lucia: Ah, I can't finish this, I can't finish this, oh my god, help!
Alice:Lucy啊你好了吗
Alice: Lucia, are you done?
Lucia: 快了快了
Lucia: Almost, almost.
Alice:我的差不多了
Alice: I'm almost done.
Lucia: 哈哈我快了快了
Lucia: Haha, I'm almost done.
Alice:需要我帮你吗
Alice: Do you need my help?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mm.
Lucia: 那个
Lucia: Um.
Lucia: 或者可心你可以帮我把这几只鸟
Lucia: Or, Kexin, can you help me with these birds?
Lucia: 就是翅膀
Lucia: Just the wings.
Lucia: 两个翅膀尖这里都像这样子
Lucia: The tips of both wings, like this.
Lucia: 就你这样卷一下然后这样粘嘛
Lucia: You just roll it like this and stick it.
Lucia: 它就跟双面胶一样
Lucia: It works like double-sided tape.
Lucia: 然后就可以把它粘在墙上好吗谢谢
Lucia: Then you can stick it on the wall. Okay, thanks.
Lucia: 有一些
Lucia: Some of them...
Lucia: 有一些小的我就直接撕开贴了
Lucia: Some of the small ones, I just stick directly.
Lucia: 因为那些小的我觉得肯肯定能撕下来
Lucia: Because I think the small ones will definitely stick.
Lucia: 但是像大一点的就不敢这样贴
Lucia: But I don't dare to stick the bigger ones like that.
Lucia: come back
Lucia: Come back.
Lucia: 这里有好几只鸟
Lucia: There are several birds here.
Lucia: 谢谢可心
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin.
Lucia: 我马上就回来
Lucia: I'll be right back.
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 耶
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 回向拉满
Shure: Full echo.
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you, thank you.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Lucia: 非常感谢啊
Lucia: Thanks a lot.
Lucia: 感觉胜利在望了
Lucia: I feel victory is in sight.
Lucia: 那个鱼哎呀就不做了
Lucia: As for the fish, forget it.
Lucia: 我就直接把它放在那就行
Lucia: I'll just put it there.
其他人：屌了全忘了
Others: Damn, we forgot everything.
Alice:hello Lucy啊
Alice: Hello, Lucia.
Jake:hello
Jake: Hello.
Alice:这是啊你的好可爱
Alice: This is... it's so cute.
Lucia: 嗯谢谢我的梳子
Lucia: Mm, thanks. My comb.
Alice:好像花知晓的风格
Lucia: 这个好像是
Lucia: This seems to be
Lucia: 反正这个有一段时间特别火
Lucia: Anyway, this was really popular for a while.
Alice:可爱
Alice: Cute.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then
Alice:感觉你会魔法
Alice: Feels like you can do magic.
Lucia: 哎我就是会魔法
Lucia: Yeah, I can do magic.
Lucia: 你看的非常准确
Lucia: You saw it very accurately.
Lucia: 我其实是一个魔法人
Lucia: I'm actually a magician.
Lucia: 魔法魔法
Lucia: Magic, magic.
Lucia: 魔法什么呀
Lucia: What kind of magic?
Lucia: 魔法少女
Lucia: Magic girl.
Alice:魔法少者使者
Alice: Magic girl envoy.
Lucia: 感觉好像还行
Lucia: Feels like it's okay.
Alice:这小鱼好可爱
Alice: This little fish is so cute.
Lucia: 嗯对本来想把它挂在渔网里的
Lucia: Yeah, I originally wanted to hang it in the fishing net.
Lucia: 然后发现好对
Lucia: Then I found out it was too heavy.
Alice:太沉了吧
Alice: Too heavy, right?
Lucia: 然后就把它放在那了
Lucia: So I just put it there.
Lucia: 贴了一个胶带
Lucia: Taped it up.
Lucia: 然后这个床还要铺一下
Lucia: And this bed still needs to be made.
Lucia: 好烦啊我靠嗯
Lucia: So annoying, ugh, yeah.
Lucia: 啊我天包累死
Lucia: Ah, my god, I'm exhausted.
Alice:杨老板这个要不要先导一波呀
Alice: Jake, should we start a round of this?
Alice:下午还录吗
Alice: Are we recording in the afternoon?
Alice:现在还有
Alice: There's still
Alice:40.77
Alice: 40.77
Alice:好但是现在12点半了
Alice: Okay, but it's already 12:30 now.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 黑色的卧槽
Shure: Black, oh my god.
Shure: 这黑色的人家是
Shure: This black is
Shure: 高高贵的黑色
Shure: Noble black.
Shure: 你可以把它平铺到这上面斜边珠
Shure: You can lay it flat over this with a diagonal edge.
Shure: 单线程
Shure: Single-threaded.
Shure: 就脑子里面只有一个一个目标是吧
Shure: Just one goal in mind, right?
Shure: 钢琴他都弹不好
Shure: He can't even play the piano well.
Shure: 这心乱了
Shure: His mind is all over the place.
Shure: （歌词）我要抱着你
Shure: (Lyrics) I want to hold you.
Shure: （歌词）直到不能呼吸
Shure: (Lyrics) Until I can't breathe.
Shure: （歌词）为了你
Shure: (Lyrics) For you.
Shure: （歌词）愿意
Shure: (Lyrics) Willing.
Shure: （歌词）如果全世
Shure: (lyrics) If the whole world
其他人：操
Others: Damn
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Shure: （歌词）不去珍惜
Shure: (lyrics) doesn't cherish
Shure: （歌词）而你在这里我总记得在哪里
Shure: (lyrics) and you're here, I always remember where
Shure: （歌词）如果全世界我也可以忘记
Shure: (lyrics) If I could forget the whole world
Shure: （歌词）至少还有你值得我去珍惜
Shure: (lyrics) At least there's you worth cherishing
Shure: （歌词）你相信那是生命的奇迹
Shure: (lyrics) Do you believe that's the miracle of life
其他人：哎你们那个电脑不是黑的吗
Others: Hey, isn't your computer black?
Shure: 我们都是深空灰的其实
Shure: Actually, ours are all space gray
Shure: 不是就是整个颜色就是不一样
Shure: No, the whole color is just different
Shure: 我们是灰的你这
Shure: Ours is gray, yours is
Shure: 而且黑色的都显大感觉
Shure: And black ones always look bigger
Lucia: 咦咦呃
Lucia: Eww
其他人：借个充电宝
Others: Can I borrow a power bank?
Jake:当然不能拔啊
Jake: Of course you can't unplug it
Jake:那不能拿走
Jake: You can't take it away
其他人：这么好看的吗
Others: Is it really that good-looking?
Jake:楼下怎么样啊
Jake: How's downstairs?
Jake:现在干净吗
Jake: Is it clean now?
其他人：非常干净
Others: Very clean
Jake:哈哈你们这
Jake: Haha, you guys
其他人：我反正看非常干净
Others: I think it's very clean
Jake:外边呢
Jake: What about outside?
Jake:快赶紧个球赶紧出去
Jake: Hurry up, go out quickly
Jake:把那个外面收拾收拾吧嗯
Jake: Go tidy up outside, okay?
Jake:对楼下外头
Jake: Yes, downstairs outside
Jake:刘帅干嘛呢
Jake: Choiszt, what are you doing?
Jake:下去哈哈
Jake: Go down, haha
Shure: 我靠走这么远
Shure: Damn, we walked so far
其他人：这是干啥的连你电脑的吗
Others: What is this for? Is it connected to your computer?
其他人：马上用斯坦福的钢琴给大家弹
Others: I'm about to play the Stanford piano for everyone
Tasha: 斯坦福
Tasha: Stanford?
其他人：必须的 800万
Others: Definitely, 8 million
Tasha: 是斯坦威
Tasha: It's Steinway
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:完了完了完了完了都录上了
Jake: Oh no, oh no, it's all recorded
Shure: 露怯了
Shure: Embarrassed ourselves
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey
Jake:what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Jake:哎哟好看
Jake: Oh wow, this looks great.
Jake:我的这个在哪儿啊
Jake: Where's mine?
其他人：你连上了是吧
Others: You connected, right?
Shure: 连上了
Shure: Yeah, connected.
其他人：那我把我的声音关了
Others: Then I'll mute myself.
其他人：我操
Others: Damn.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Oh sh*t.
Shure: 哈哈好
Shure: Haha, alright.
Shure: 呵呵呵你别一脸高潮的样子好吗
Shure: Haha, don't look so thrilled.
其他人：批准了
Others: Approved.
其他人：这个你吃吗
Others: Are you eating this?
Jake:啊今天要吃很多的
Jake: Ah, we'll be eating a lot today.
Jake:因为要做很多
Jake: Because we have to make a lot.
其他人：为什么
Others: Why?
其他人：今天还要做啊少做点
Others: We're still making more today? Let's make less.
其他人：死我也不吃
Others: I won't eat it even if it kills me.
其他人：那我吃了
Others: Then I'll eat it.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Lucia: 没有一点办法
Lucia: There's no way.
Shure: （歌词）没有一点点防备
Shure: (lyrics) No preparation at all.
Shure: （歌词）也没有一丝顾虑
Shure: (lyrics) No hesitation either.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Shure: 垫个垫应该更高一点哎
Shure: If we add a cushion, it should be higher.
Shure: 斯坦福你弹的是斯坦福钢琴
Shure: Stanford, you're playing a Stanford piano.
Jake:就凭这句话你就得有一只offer
Jake: Just for saying that, you deserve an offer.
Jake:录下来了
Jake: Got it recorded.
其他人： 我是收拾完之后你做蛋糕
Others: After I clean up, you make the cake.
Jake:收拾完之后吃饭
Jake: After eating, we'll eat again.
Jake:做蛋糕差不多对就结了
Jake: Once the cake is done, that's about it.